hi my name is carly rae jepsen and i am
so excited to have my new album
dedicated out now i'm also really
nervous and excited for my first ever
staring contest i'm gonna lose it so it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
I'm not great at slurring contest but
I'm excited
I know they're drying now it's okay well
I think I blinked you win okay now I ask
you a question okay
hey wait cut to the feeling was recently
used as a lip sync number on season 10
of RuPaul's Drag Race and as we all know
the gays love you
facts are facts America Oh would you
ever make a guest judge appearance on
the show if you're listening that's yes
just call me
make me laugh that's not bad there if we
start to cry first do we get extra
points but I think we kind of tied I'm
pretty sure I figure we are the blinking
police here okay where is the sword you
were given at last year's Lollapalooza
we've been given a few sort okay yeah
I think that Alex whatever chair
managers took it home with him because
we were trying to get on the plane and
he screenshot it he was going to New
York and he's screenshotted a picture of
it wrapped up and going through the
little security and we were like Fred
what are you gonna put it you can't
bring a needle and thread but you can
bring this sword
no sorry
your fans love to comment on your
Instagram Queen up of link what's the
best you've been called the queen of oh
well it's funny I think we enjoy the van
boys and to myself the most absurd and
random ones I think my favorite all-time
line was queen of leaning on a fence cuz
I was leaning on offense
hi it's me feeling your wide how did you
decide the tricorder we knew of your
album dedicated and do you have a
favorite lyric from the album I locked
myself in the house for about three or
four days straight with my assistant and
just try different just different
patterns of what felt like a good track
order and every time I get it right I
would tap dance and then order more food
like it was a stressful process but we
got through it Gemma actually has some
footage that no one may ever see a black
man it was maybe from the sound I just
it's a really casual lyric about
relationships and it's just like God you
make me so tired it's a vision that you
wanted hello a working title for your
new album was music to clean at your
house too huh why did you end up going
with dedicated for the album title well
it was always Marvin joke the title
music to clean your house - it was sort
of concepted by the idea of it that's
what I wasn't worth listening back here
when I was setting it to friends I feel
like here's some news for your house -
but dedicated um it just ended up being
a good wrap-up of what I had gone
through already miss exploring what it
is to be dedicated in love and also a
dedication to to friends and
our I don't know our travelling
community I love that you can still
clean our house to it and it's best if
you clean your house do it I'll get to
hitting for it stone we know you changed
the original direction of your new album
away from chilled disco is there a
chance we'll get to hear these those
songs in an eventual dedicated side beat
yes it might not be called beside beat
I'm not sure I don't know when it's
happening I have dreams of that
happening there's no point in writing
200 songs and only getting to share 15 I
mean that's just crazy so I'm hoping to
be able to share some of my other
favorites and actually that list is just
as exciting to me as the first round
sight I can't wait
[Music]